mannequins are during the reverse
Michael Jackson we're here on a cute
little shopping date California water
show behind us is going off with the
music it's so beautiful here we love
coming here on the weekend sometimes and
just hanging out they have this grassy
area where you can lay out a blanket and
hang out there to be Christmas and
Christmas occupy the entire space thanks
Christmas thank you very much yeah so
now they're decorating for Christmas or
he can't go out and lay out by the grass
let it sit there I love it here cuz it
feels really like European it feels very
I don't know like it's just a different
part of the world every time you're in
New York like Central Park is like for
San Francisco oh yeah so we're gonna be
stopping and we have some lunch and we
just want to bring you guys along for
the ride I just I'm not bothering you oh
you're in the shade I'm in the shade
there we go yeah oh and then I actually
tried putting eyeshadow on today guys
that he's big
yeah I didn't put any eyeliner or
anything I try to I try to again what do
you think taking notes
what's that rematch I know you take it I
know we should attempt that again and
then this time I'm going to try my best
to not be a control freak and to just
let go let you take over so we might end
up doing another video maybe I don't
know do another video Casey do my break
though I know there's a lot of comments
saying that you guys want to see me do
Casey's makeup but it's just gonna turn
out like they're just gonna look like a
kpop star no I'm I'm saying that it's
just gonna turn out like this I don't
know how to do anything else
we're gonna go it's like our little
inside jokes okay because watch the day
he gets from way back when we feel like
a black Fridays good why do you want to
do tonight
like I said before I'm very cheap so
cheap
[Music]
[Applause]
that's going on this season do you like
following the seasons and like the
trends of each season I'm like so not a
fashionista at all I just buy things I
like and I wear them whenever I want to
wear them I don't really pay attention
to like season
and everything just matched it looks
good on you there's just lays on your
body and just it just shines that's
really saw my arms are short like reach
like a hot look it's like one of those
it's like a contradictory look it's
always look high like ugh then boot
short yes I love seeing the homeless
look at stores
that's the discount look like I want my
discount on that it's rich watching like
10 years we're gonna start wearing that
- I know I know I'm super late on
fashion so give me five more years and
if I start wearing Holi shirts too
look it's like your turn Elmo into water
you should get that I actually like it
you be my Elmo and I'll tickle you crazy
so that's the style now if you got to
look like that
and look like that okay that's true
they're marking it towards the people
that travel to places that are cold but
you know what's funny though just on the
way here you're saying the next time we
travel you want to go somewhere tropical
you know I keep going a cold place
too many I'm here to focus on top that's
the goal
today the sweaters count by it's just
their arms or that's the shoulder is
that for the shoulder the arms I was
gonna say it looks very bondage but
thank you 26 cool to SNM decisions
decisions
I hate shopping so whenever I do come
and shop I always see a lot of things
that I like but for some reason I'm like
I know I'm not gonna wear it even though
I like you you guys have that problem I
have a lot of shoes at home and I buy
like red shoes and like just different
color shoes but I never wear them
because I'm just not into wearing
colored shoes I like gray white and
black shoes I think you buy it because
they use if you want to tell yourself
like I'm gonna step out of my bubble I'm
gonna try something new and then you
never do because I have so many shoes
also I have so many high heels that I
just love you're so cute and they never
wear them I think this is like the most
heel that I wear like
I don't like wearing like stiletto kind
of heels even though I own so many pairs
of shoes that I've got and then I have
so many items of clothing that are just
so cute like less like a Halloween
costume yes the material of Halloween
costume it's a squished tomato costume
you know have this tomato costume that's
the squished version I mean sorry
crushed Tomatoes lean on I don't know
[Applause]
yes google it girl of the 21st century
look she would wear this holographic
stuff like this is something she would
own you know I feel better now you
didn't remember you well actually you
remember it high five
I am really diagnosis from sort of OCD
because every time I come shopping and I
see something on the flash you pick it
up I'm just like do it just shop off the
floor here how about this one it's been
pre-selected for you exchange opinion of
what we picked out that's true but I
guess today we're vlogging this stuff
can work this looks like one of those
movie suits for a for CG you know like
Gollum or something or King Kong who
would wear this you look like a science
project
[Music]
I actually thought that was gonna feel
like a Christmas tree but it didn't it
felt very soft like that whole corner
over there it's like my grandma's closet
like that's literally when my
grandfather was like Conor McGregor hey
your model way better than me you're
like way more serious cuz I end up
feeling really goofy when I muscle
that's your holding in a fart
[Music]
you've been trying to find like a jacket
it's really not bad not bad it's kind of
like a blazer slash sweater slash
something I like it you should take it
yeah what do you guys think you know we
should do a thing where we shop for each
other
well I mean I already shop for you but
you do everything that you do not like
[Music]
sweet
[Music]
[Music]
looking at the men's section here at H&M
and feel like I like this better than 25
21 some money already well we're here to
spend money that's why we go shopping I
like to budget myself three things is
alive it's like almost $100 if you have
a brown jacket I know I brought it I've
brought it bad Alessa in the car - looks
good it makes you look more buff huh I
like it only 60 bucks it's another bad
[Applause]
the fur is in right now you rock it well
though I mean you need it like one of
those furry hats now like those Russian
girls
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ruin my diet weekend no yesterday was
kind of my cheat day you know what I did
for my wife she was craving pumpkin pie
now went on to go buy something
[Music]
the point is we can finally drew it in
yesterday like daven and ate like three
slices octopi I regret it
today we're now rationing check
that's true I'll be singing a different
song when if we get terms really good
actually
[Music]
better than in and out
[Applause]
[Music]
don't like it as many different
and I always like to ask she liked it
we go to different burger places David
shake shack is better than any no in my
opinion yes but would you really want to
trust my face but I'm not a foodie at
all I'm just like oh whatever picky
eater person but thank you I've actually
you bother you value my opinion I do
because this day and age thanks to
social media everyone is entitled to
their opinion
[Music]